the vague has a very novel idea for how
to raise money for his residential
campaign here's a truth of how political
fundraising actually works there's a
tiny group it's an oligopoly of people
who raise money bundling and otherwise
who get to keep a large percentage
sometimes up to 10 percent of what they
actually raise that doesn't make any
sense but if that's the system we're
gonna have my view is let's democratize
that and make it possible for everybody
to make money as well so if you're
supporting me and you're part of this
movement and you want to help us
actually raise that money join my
kitchen cabinet new program we're
launching where you help me raise the
money you get a unique link to do it I'm
going to keep giving you phone calls
telling you how I think you can be most
effective for us but the money you raise
you get to keep 10 percent of it
I love it